the rumor mill has been suggesting that
an upgraded version of the PlayStation 4
is on its way for a while now and today
sources have revealed brand new details
to giant Bob allegedly multiple sources
confirm that the new system which is
internally referred to as the nao or neo
will feature a higher clock speed than
the original ps4 and improved GPU and
higher memory bandwidth documents
obtained by giant bomb state that
starting in October every ps4 game is
required to ship with a base mode for
the original ps4 and a near mode for use
on the new console which will take
advantage of the hardware upgrades and
support 4k image output although the
games themselves will not need to be
four key native within the document Sony
repeatedly reminds developers that the
frame rate of games in any air mode must
meet or exceed at the frame rate for the
original system they also confirm there
will be no any o only games or features
and players on the new console will not
be separated from those using the
original ps4 basically it appears to be
suggesting that the neo is just a more
technically and graphically capable
version of the ps4 reportedly games
released in the late September window
will require a day-one patch to update
them to neo standards the documents add
that dabs can release any already games
before the system itself launches let me
know what you think of the nao ps4 in
that comment box and we'll keep you
updated on any and all developments on
gamespot